foreign
Georgia and talk to Sophia Sophia how we
doing what's going on
pretty good how are you excellent
excellent what's happening
right so I'm calling because I wanted to
ask you or get your opinion your help
um I have an 18 year old daughter who
basically has no
she doesn't have a good relationship
with her father
um where'd he go
well he's he's around
um they I can give you a little bit of a
back story
um so him and I we were never married we
never lived together but they you know
he would always see her
um up until about 13 when she turned 13.
uh they had a pretty good relationship
you know she'd go over there every other
weekend and during the week and whatnot
um at 13 she started playing
um Sports softball to be
um
uh precise and so
um he got her into really competitive
um teams and whatnot and it seemed like
he was it was more so for him than it
was for her eventually
um so she wasn't really enjoying it as
much as uh he wanted her to yep
um and so she wasn't fulfilling his
dreams as much as we needed them to be
fulfilled by his daughter so ridiculous
exactly So eventually she got out of the
competitive teams and she just stuck
with high school ball and middle school
or whatnot
um after that it seemed like their
relationship just went downhill
um because he would always complain and
say you know she didn't want the
responsibility she didn't want she was
13. right
oh my gosh you are you are pushing my
buttons it is early this morning I know
it
um
to every parent listening
you're
your kid is not a window through which
sole purpose is for you to relive your
childhood
and your kids
think about it it's another kid tossing
a ball and another kid hitting it with a
stick
are chasing us anyway all right I I can
get derailed here and it's too early to
be drinking so go ahead go ahead
Okay so
so bye and um she's she's 18 now so she
just graduated high school
um and throughout the years he was he
just kind of got a little out of her
life
um little by little I think the whole
softball thing was what triggered it and
then he would just say oh well when I
call her she barely talks to me or if I
text her she just answers with you know
hi or no or you know one word answers or
whatnot
um and I remember I'd always tell him
well you know she's a teenager I don't
think she particularly wants to sit down
and have a huge conversation about life
with our dad right now or her mom for
that matter you know
um so he would always complain about
that he is an immature coward
yeah and if you've listened to the show
I don't throw that around a lot but I'm
so sick oh the only thing worse and I
get more frustrated over
I get frustrated over kids unfettered
access to social media that's number one
I get super frustrated by parents
obsession with travel Sports and forcing
their kids along and then saying it's
for them and I especially am sick
of kids
being responsible for making mom and dad
feel special and loved and that kind of
she just responds with high or whatever
it's the parents job to show up in that
relationship because they're kids
right right right and Madness and that's
what I've always told him because he
would ask me oh well you know what do
you think the issue is and I know here's
the issue right I I would tell him you
know I think you're the one who needs to
show up you're the adult
um now that she's 18 he said well you
know she's an adult now you can't use
that same excuse and I said well you
never really tried either you know and
so I guess at the end of the day what
I'm wanting to
to know is if I should tell her hey why
don't you try and have a relationship
with him just because I don't want her
feeling like what did I do for my dad
not to love me she's gonna feel that no
matter what because her dad doesn't
right so you're trying to
create a fantasy that's not real
okay I am heartbroken for you that your
daughter's dad
is such a spineless coward that he's
walked out on his daughter
I'm sorry because I know that
you love your daughter a lot and you
don't want to see her hurt like she's
going to hurt
great and she is
told me she doesn't you know it doesn't
bother her it doesn't matter of course
she has to say I know it does she has to
say that
um
jeez man I
yes she is going to miss her dad
and she is going to find all sorts of
substitutes in life to fill that massive
massive hole in her heart
um
but he's a spineless coward
and that's all there is to it it's all
there is to it
um even the language of well she's an
adult now you can't use that yes you can
because I've seen 70 year old parents
who are abusive and who were dogmatic
and who were obsessive about this is my
religion or my rules or my I'm right
and they finally dropped that charade
nonsense and they said hey you're my kid
I love you and the kid was 38.
and I've seen healing there too but it
has to come from Mom and Dad
because they're the parent
yeah and your sweet little girl doesn't
have that
and so
if I'm here's the deal the only thing I
can tell you here I don't have like a a
clinical study to back up what I'm going
to say I'm just going to tell you that
if I was sitting across from my daughter
and her mom had just mysteriously
laughed and then would say things like
whenever I text her she just writes back
one one word letters so she doesn't even
like me what stupid crap like that uh by
the way I would you want to put a pin in
something you said before I get back to
it I know I'm all over the place because
it just gets me all fired up
um the whole idea that quote unquote
kids just naturally pull apart when
they're teenagers is actually not true
it's it's it's not born out in in the
scientific literature it's not real
they do it because they have to survive
there is some and I don't mean this in a
gross abusive way I I mean this in men
become terrified of their daughter's
sexuality and they don't know what to do
with it
and so they don't they're not creepers
they're not abusers they just disappear
and that child has to have somebody in a
relationship moms have a weird
interaction with their daughters at
times especially teenage daughters and
it's easier to just kind of back up I
don't want to get in the way they want
to be with their friends so we have a
generation of kids who are being raised
by their peers and we've heard the
studies that you know peers peer
influences more than parent influence
but that's because we have become wholly
unlikable people as parents we've
abdicated our responsibility to schools
and to screens and to
um other peers
and even even with my buddy like I was
like a youth Minister parents come up to
him and it's like hey you're going to
teach him this this and this and it's
like that's your job you're the parent
right so the parents have outsourced
everything and now kids they don't their
parents aren't trustworthy and so of
course they're going to have other
people but let me tell you something
when you meet kids who trust their
parents and whose parents are fun
likable people who also hold them
accountable I'm not talking about just
chaotic but I'm talking about who are
good solid adults it's it's incredible
to watch their kids love their parents
of course they love their boyfriend or
girlfriend and their friends but they
love their parents it's not it's not a
weird thing like it is in so many
millions of households so I'm gonna put
you want to put a pin in that if I'm you
and I'm having this conversation
um
I would sit down before my daughter goes
to college and let her know something
was wrong with that not you
and I'm I'm heartbroken and sad that Dad
chose immaturity and Dad chose
um
uh other things
but that she is not the problem that is
yeah and I've had that conversation with
her because
uh like on Father's Day or on his
birthday if she texts him or calls the
first thing he says oh you finally
remembered or oh you remembered because
it's a special day or whatever
so I'm thinking you know why would he
even do that to her
he's an immature she's a child he's a
child
yeah
and so yeah here's what you cannot do
two years Sophia you can't do this you
cannot put this burden on her
right okay
and you can tell her I'm really
heartbroken that
um you don't have a good relationship
with your dad because that's such an
important part of human development is
having a good relationship with with
your mom and your dad and you don't have
that I'm so so sorry I think that um I
think that conversation is true and real
and maybe
um woman to woman saying hey here's how
you might go looking for that
relationship out out in the world don't
or here's how to do this wisely right
um because that that that leaning will
be there uh Mr Philip help fill up that
other that Gap but
oh man
um don't put the emotional regulation of
of an immature dad on an 18 year old
girl she can't carry that weight it's
not her it's not her responsibility at
some point if she chooses
and again not as an 18 year old I'm
talking about a 22 25 like she's
established she's got a job she's
figuring out life if she chooses to say
I want to be in relationship with this
guy I want to have something to do with
him I know he's immature I'm not coming
to him to fulfill my needs like I'm not
coming to him as a daughter trying to be
full and loved but I do want to know my
old man
um that's that's totally her idea and I
would 100 support that
but she would be going all it's almost
informational at that point it's almost
I want to learn about myself it's it's
self-exploration
um more than it is
um some sort of
um cathartic healing relationship
dad left her man
in every stage he's left her
and when she quit and here's here's the
The Meta when she quit performing for
him
which she could perform for him he was
in and when she could uh make him feel
good about himself uh she was in
but he didn't have the capacity to make
her feel loved and seen
and I hate that for everybody I'm sorry
but for for all the oh gosh all the
parents listening
it's not your kid's job to make you feel
loved I don't care how old they are
it's your job
it's your job to make them feel loved
and if they don't text you the right way
or they don't call you the right way or
they do call you don't start off with
passive aggressive oh so now you decide
to just answer the phone and say oh my
gosh everything in my day is better
because I get to hear your voice I'm so
glad you called
and by the way don't wait for your kids
to call be an adult
be a grown-up be a parent you call
let them tell you oh let them roll their
eyes and you keep calling and keep
calling because
never let them think for a second
I don't have a safe place to go with
with him I don't have a safe place to go
with her
golly